images d'art car je vous le dis tout de
suite
est ce qu'on a dit ou pas vu sur idf1
une voyante perdre patience en pleine
consultation
oui ouais c'est exceptionnel
exceptionnel c'est toujours en direct
pratiquement inouïe ballon toujours nous
sommes à pratiquer une fellation
marseille à rien voilà voilà
vous allez me dire stop pas par rapport
à la rencontre affective d'accord
dites-moi stop vous le sentez oui c'est
bon là je considère que c'est cette
chaîne ont au nom des fans je vous le
dis elle fête ses 10 ans et est ce qu'on
a vu un téléspectateur d'idf a raconté
la vie personnelle de jacky à l'antenne
on l'a vu regarder tf1 c'est que cette
histoire enfin jacky mais rejeté que
j'étais avec avec toi donc ouais ouais
ça lui soit sans palmes qui m'appelle
toile et drôle allez on n'a pas eu très
peur le commissaire l'union
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est fou ce qui se passe sur cette
chaîne sur l'année est-ce qu'on avait
une animatrice à l'antenne d'idf1
recevoir beaucoup trop de tweets à la
fois non
regardez c'est plutôt le contraire sur
twitter michel qui nous dit je me
souviens de milices à toute timide à
saison dernière pas d'évolution bravo à
elle dont elle a beaucoup savons que
merci beaucoup michel et puis
et puis voilà donc on dit par rapport
aux non chercher de nouveaux tweets mais
n'en attendais pas du tout est ce qu'on
a vu l'idf à diffuser le film érotique
hélène dans les garçons dont la non aux
caisses bien dans ce tir vétéran des
garçons en thaïlande a été mieux mais
est ce que la vie m'a dit merci merci de
votre intérêt
mais ce qu'on a vu une animatrice d'idf1
connaître personnellement tous ses
téléspectateurs regardent et il avait
regardé c'est impressionnant est-ce
qu'on a récupéré un appel ou je continue
de parler hommages continuent de parler
assez bon d'accord ok alors bonjour à
philippe né 13 octobre 61
hemani jacky ido qu'animateur sur et des
bas et on va vous dire qu'ils qui a été
la personne qui était derrière l'arrêt
du club dorothée vous allez voir c'est
où je vous dire ça dans un instant est
ce qu'on a vu camille combal appelé id
voyance pour connaître son avenir
sentimental il nous l'avait fait ici
c'était ouf regarde je m'appelle qu la
nuit camille votre date de naissance
camille s'il vous plaît le 18 septembre
80 un bon jour sur guillaume bonjour
qu'émile alors ma question en fait une
question sentimentale j'ai vécu une
rupture il ya pas longtemps est
quelqu'un avec qui je lui donnais mes
plus belles années là depuis quelques
jours on a rompu
j'aurais aimé savoir qui peut être je
pourrai retrouver des traînées alors
donnez moi son prénom à votre ami sai
baba bab à ckoi babar mai à berne
d'accord en avant l'un en amont est-ce
qu'on abuse des centres et la télé ce
fait des spectatrices un cadeau d'une
valeur de plusieurs milliers d'euros
non c'est non c'est impossible jacking
impossible impossible
non c'est vrai que le budget cadeau est
un peu ric rac on avait diffusé à
quelques années cet extrait vous allez
voir le cadeau est assez dingue regarder
ça
on voit très sensuelle astrid c'est
gagner alors bravo
alors vous avez gagné une sélection de
chocolats
[Applaudissements]
alors vous avez gagné une sélection
d'albums et j'en peux plus franchement
si je suis fan
je suis fan de la chaîne ce soir c'est
vraiment ce qu'on a vu christophe
carrière jean luc lemoine et moi même
dansé sur le plateau de vous avez du
talent sur idf1
oui bien sûr je vais voir oui monsieur
fabien est venu de voir
oui c'est on va voir l'état
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
produits
vive la solution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'au début c'est vrai que
christophe faisait des mauvaises blagues
dont j'étais passé comme candidat on
l'avait mis au défi de saison c'est
comme ça au concours un délit avait été
sérieux et et christophe eide avait
perdu la vue d'animatrice d'idf1
confondre le sexe de ses téléspectateurs
a longtemps et c'est parti pour un
prochain appel à un dernier rappel
bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour comment
vous appelez-vous monsieur myriam
excusez moi a dit jacky s'occuper
lui-même des cadeaux des téléspectateurs
tellement le budget idf a reserré oui
s'implique beaucoup regardé appelez le
32 67 groupe de malades
oui un cadeau vous gagnerez la photo
dédicacée de violence et que je vous dis
qu'à serai moi même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]